Till now we have been looking at the properties of images
formed by plane mirrors.
A plane mirror is a mirror whose reflecting surface is flat
What about this mirror?
Is this also a plane mirror?
This is a mirror as it has
the smooth reflecting surface.
But this is not a plane mirror as this reflecting surface is not flat.
The reflecting surface is curved and hence this mirror
is called a curved mirror.
What about this one?
This is also a curved mirror
The difference between the two is that reflecting surface
of this mirror is curved inwards
where as the reflecting surface of this mirror is curved outwards.
Can you think of examples
where you have seen curved mirrors?
A shiny surface of a spoon is a good approximation of curved mirrors.
Spoon has two reflecting surfaces.
One curved inside and the other curved outside.
Now the specific types of curved mirrors that we
are interested in are called Spherical mirrors.
In fact, these two mirrors are spherical.
Well, they look nothing like a sphere.
But then why are they called so?
They are called spherical mirrors because  their reflecting surface
is a part of a sphere
You can clearly see that the reflecting surfaces
of both the mirrors form the part of the sphere.
Now both these are given special names
The mirror that has it's reflecting surface curved inwards
is called a concave mirror
And the mirror that has it's reflecting surface curved outwards
is called convex mirror
Yes.
Inwards - concave, and outwards - convex
Now we want to study the properties of images
formed by spherical mirrors.
But before that, we need to define certain terms
related to spherical mirrors.
So let's do that.
Both the mirror are placed like this.
Concave mirror on your left and convex mirror on your right.
I'm going to define the terms for both these mirrors
Concave - inwards, and convex - outwards
The center of the reflecting surface of the mirror is called the pole
We represent it with a point P
In the front view of both the mirrors
You can't see that the pole is present right at the center
Now as I told you, the reflecting surface
forms a section of the sphere.
This sphere must have a center
This center of the sphere is called center of curvature
denoted by C
And what will the radius be called?
Yes, it's called the radius of curvature
Join the pole and the center of curvature with a line
This line is called the Principal Axis
The midpoint of the line segment joining the pole P
and the center of curvature C
is called the focal point
It's denoted by the letter F
We will talk about one last thing in this video
And that is an assumption we are making all along
We are assuming the radius of the curvature of a mirror,
to be must greater then the aperture of the mirror
Aperture, in simple terms, is that part of the mirror
which is exposed to light.
In our mirror
this is its aperture
since the light can be incident any where in this region.
If we hide some part of the mirror with an opaque substance
then it's aperture is reduced.
Mathematically it is this length.
So the mirror that we are considering is the one in which the aperture
is much smaller then the radius of the curvature.
These were a few of the terms related to spherical mirrors.
But there's a lot more we need to understand about them.
See you in the next video.